[MUSIC PLAYING]
TAD HUNT: All right, we're
live, as everyone fills in.
Hi, everybody.
Hope you're having
fun at Next today.
We're here to talk to you
today about Cloud Filestore,
our new service for managed
files for your applications.
I'm Tad Hunt.
I'm the product manager
for Cloud Filestore.
Been at Google for
about two and 1/2 years.
As you can see from my picture,
my main hobby is rock climbing.
That's from up in
Tuolumne, Matthes Crest.
Awesome climb.
KASHI VISHWANATH: Good morning.
I'm Kashi.
I'm the engineering manager for
the Cloud Filestore product.
I don't have a hobby
picture up there.
But unlike my friend Tad,
who likes to climb up,
I'm afraid of heights.
I like to explore the
horizontal territories.
So biking is my passion.
And I used to think I'm
really into biking till I
was told that unless I do
the Seattle to Portland ride,
I can't claim that I'm a biker.
So I did that STP a
couple of weekends back.
So you can see how
we tussle, right?
One likes to scale up
and I like to scale out.
Never mind.
Back to Tad.
TAD HUNT: All right,
well, so hopefully you're
woken up from all that.
What we hope you walk away from
today from our presentation
is how Cloud Filestore can help
you simplify and accelerate
your journey in
the public cloud.
So let's see.
So introducing Cloud
Filestore beta.
You know, many of you
have been telling us
that you want a native managed
first class offering for files
in Google Cloud.
Can everybody hear
me OK in the back?
All right.
Awesome.
Cool.
We'll talk a little bit
about use cases later.
But, for now, let's say, it's
going to unblock your small
and your midsize
compute clusters
in scale and enterprise
applications,
you know, things that need
access to shared file systems.
NFS and shared file systems
are like the arteries
of the enterprise workflows.
So it's about time we had
a file offering, I think.
And so we're super excited to
get this out there for you all.
We just launched a
beta on July 12th.
And so it's really early days.
We're already seeing
really amazing uptake.
We announced it about
10 business days
prior when we launched
our LA region.
And we've got about 1,500
people signing up with interest.
And so really,
really pretty cool.
So let me just take a minute
to talk about the ecosystem.
Where does Filestore
store fit in?
And so, this is like the
taxonomy of storage systems
in Google Cloud today.
We're not going to spend
any time on anything other
than File.
I just wanted to
show you all this so
that you can see the rich
ecosystem that Filestore's
a part of and get a view into
the cutting-edge computer
science that we're doing
here in Google Cloud
so that you can run
your apps much better.
So if we zoom in on the
unstructured storage systems,
you know that's file,
object, and block,
each are good at solving
different problems
in sort of different domains.
If we take a file-centric
view on these domains,
shared file systems are
critical building blocks
in enterprise workflows.
But if you're going to manually
stand up Linux instances
and build your own
file servers, that's
complex and time consuming.
And then you're still in the
business of managing filers,
keeping them up to
date, and so on.
You can try object storage for
your workloads that need File.
But sometimes making
object storage
try and look like File is--
let's say, it just makes
us grumpy and kind of
leave it at that.
If there's not an impedance
mismatch with your workload,
sometimes it works really well.
But if there is, then
you need a random I/O,
then it's kind of a disaster.
And then finally, we have some
really innovative, persistent
disk features, which are
our virtual disks such
that you can mount read-only
the same virtual disk
on a whole huge number of VMs.
But it's not writable.
And so, while persistent disk
is good for a certain kind
of unstructured data, it's
not awesome for sharing files.
In fact, that's what
network-attached storage
was invented for.
And so that's what this is.
KASHI VISHWANATH: So with that,
you understand, hopefully,
where in the old portfolio of
Google-managed native storage
solutions for unstructured
store Filestore fits in.
Let me tell you a little bit
of things right off the bat.
As Tad said, we launched beta.
Woohoo.
So, in fact, right after this
talk, I encourage all of you
to play with it, share feedback.
Many of the room
have already done so.
Being a managed,
native Google product,
you get all the goodness
that comes with Google.
It's managed, fully supported
by a dedicated [INAUDIBLE] team.
It's integrated with Kubernetes
engine and DC Compute Engine.
And that GA time, you'll
get zonal [INAUDIBLE]
server availability.
So it's first party, which will
come with its own use cases
that Tad will now
walk you through.
TAD HUNT: Cool.
So I'm not going to
read all these words.
It's a lot of words.
A lot of you are
taking pictures.
That's, I think, an awesome way.
But let me talk to you
about the highlights here.
We've designed Filestore to
be great at many enterprise
workloads.
In particular, we've
tuned it already
at beta for these top five.
If you're in the
rendering space,
if your building
render farms, you
might have many, many
compute instances, maybe
preemtable instances
that are spinning up
batched-processed
workloads here.
That's great.
We've tuned it for that.
If you're migrating enterprise
applications to the Cloud,
does NFSv3 and does all
the basic NFS operations
that you're used to.
You might be running
infrastructure-supporting
websites like WordPress
or stuff like that.
And so that tends to
need lots of small file--
high performance,
small file access.
We've got you covered there too.
On the media side, we've
got artists using Filestore
to collaborate on their desktops
and their desktop workstations
while they're doing
the real-time--
building the 3D models
that will eventually
be rendered into the movies.
And in fact, if you
go to Moscone West up
on the second floor, we've
got a team of artists
back over in a corner
that are actually doing
a real-time commercial, building
an animated commercial for GCP.
They're running virtual
desktops in the Cloud,
in GCP, using scale out GPUs
for doing really high quality,
real-time rendering.
And they're using
Filestore behind the scenes
to share all the files
between all the artists.
So pretty cool.
And then, can't leave
out home directories.
You know, home
directories are often
done on shared file systems
in order for management,
keeping data safe and protected
and to do backups, and so on,
and so all great use
cases for Filestore.
KASHI VISHWANATH: So we're
introducing the Filestore
product in two tiers.
Right off the bat, as
you can probably tell,
the biggest difference between
the two tiers is performance.
In fact, the only difference
is price and performance.
So you are the best judge of the
application you have at hand.
But we have a few suggestions
and recommendations for you.
If you find that you're
running a read-write, random
read-write, data-intensive
workload, for example,
a simulation, then you may want
to opt in for the premium tier
to tap into the full IOPS
that we can export to you.
On the other hand, if you
expect that your application is
more cache friendly, then
you can pay a lot less
and get away with
the standard tier
and get the cache-read
performance.
But as we all know,
performance tuning is an art.
So you're the best judge of
what your application needs.
Apart from the trifecta of
IOPS, throughput, and latency,
and we've shared some
numbers, but you'll
be the best judge when you try
our product, the other design
principle that we had in mind is
to make it super simple for you
to reason about your
storage to the extent
that when you go ahead
and create your Filestore
instance, at that
point, we will tell you
what sort of performance
guarantees you should expect.
So no more complex
modeling to figure out
how that performance
is going to vary.
The second thing, you're going
to get a really simple billing
model.
Again, when you create
the Filestore instance,
based on the
capacity you choose,
you're going to know
how much you will
be billed on an hourly basis.
It is not going to
change because you throw
a varying workload over time.
That does not seem fair.
And we didn't want to do it.
So those are the
design principles.
You can read the numbers
off of the charts.
But there'll be more docs later.
And, again, as I said,
you'll get a chance
to run with the product.
That's a lot of
numbers and explanation
we have done for a while, Tad.
TAD HUNT: Yeah.
KASHI VISHWANATH:
Do you think we
should show whether this
thing actually works or not?
TAD HUNT: Does anyone
want to see a demo?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TAD HUNT: Yeah.
KASHI VISHWANATH: OK.
TAD HUNT: Let's do it.
Can you search for the demo?
KASHI VISHWANATH: So we
were talking about the UI
to create the Filestore,
the standard DC UI,
you would see that there
is a Filestore product
in the storage category now.
Woohoo, that's us.
You click on that.
And it takes you to the list
of all Filestore instances
you've created so far.
So let me create one while
we're talking about it.
So I go to the Create page.
And like any GC instance,
we will give it a name.
Let's call it, "live
demo," because what better
name to pick.
We talked about the tiers.
So let me pick the
standard tier for now,
which is the one which
I would pick if I have
a sequential
workload, possibly one
which is cache friendly, right?
And I would pay a lot less.
I would pick a region.
So let me pick europe-west4-a.
In the fileshare
properties, I would
have to pick a mount point.
So let me call it,
"Live Mount Point."
And right now you can see I can
choose whatever size I want.
So let me go with the minimum,
which is one terabytes.
On the right side, we show
you the performance numbers
it gets.
Let me get this going.
And it's going to create
in the background.
And it's going to show me a
spinner that the fileshare is
being created.
In the meantime, let
me go to this line.
And these are all the fileshares
I have mounted from a single GC
instance.
For example, you can see there
are two standard filers, which
are roughly 1 and 1/2
and 2 and 1/2 terabytes.
There are two premiums, both
around 2 and 1/2 terabytes.
Here is a filer that
I have previously
created, a fileshare instance.
If I click on it, it shows me
the mount point that I can use.
And then mount here
if I do it correctly.
So while that is
happening, maybe I
changed my mind,
that I don't want
it to be a one terabyte filer.
Maybe your workload grew over
time and you need to expand it.
Luckily, that's as simple
as going here and saying
increase my fileshare
and let that happen.
So it's going to do
that in the background.
And your file system
is available for using
in the meantime.
Let me show you a
couple more things.
When I tried to create
a Filestore instance,
I talked about the
performance on the top right.
If I pick a premium instance
instead of standard,
you can see how it
shows the increased read
and write IOPS as well
as the throughput.
So again, going back to
the design principles,
keep it really simple.
When you're coming in
and creating an instance,
share everything that we have
to share about where it's
going to be created,
how large it will be,
how much it is
going to cost you,
and what are you going
to get out of it,
in terms of performance.
Again it's not going
to change because
of the usage you [INAUDIBLE].
So if you go back to this, if
you look at the last one, which
is the standard
tree, you can see
that it is 1 and 1/2
terabytes now, which
corresponds to the size increase
that we just played with.
Again, transparently, your
workload can keep running.
And you're not
going to see a blip.
This is a simple demo.
It, hopefully, shows
you that the product
that we've been talking to
you so far actually works.
We have more in store for you.
And I'll give it
back to Tad now.
TAD HUNT: Cool.
Can we switch back
to the presentation?
Pretty cool, fast
demo there, right?
Give you a good overview
of the whole thing.
Kashi demoed from the GUI.
We also have command line
and API-level access for you
as well.
All right so talking
about use cases again,
I just want to walk through
a couple of customer quotes
that we've had
for customers that
have been using this during
the alpha and at the early beta
process.
So Flywheel is a
company that does
WordPress hosting, a really,
really important customer.
Let's see.
This is a really awesome quote.
We tested WordPress in GCP on
Avere, Google Cloud Filestore
Premium, and on AWS, on EFS.
And, basically,
Filestore was the best.
So super excited about that.
Web hosting, of
course, and especially
in the WordPress land, is a
lot of small file workloads.
And so this is really important.
Charlie Rice at EVER.AI
uses Cloud Filestore
to distribute
training data to build
AI models for doing
facial recognition
on a big proprietary dataset.
"Cloud Filestore was
easy to provision
and mount and reliable for
the kind of workload we have.
Having a POSIX file system that
we can mount and use directly
helps us speed-read our files."
Really helps them.
Every time they are
adding new training data,
they gotta regenerate it.
And if the file server is
slow, then it's not awesome.
Kashi, you want
to take this one?
KASHI VISHWANATH:
Yeah, this one is
from a customer that does fuzz
testing on operating systems,
software, et cetera.
The quote from them is, "It
took one premium Cloud Filestore
instance," premium is the one
with the higher performance,
"to support a workload
that previously
required 16 powerful servers."
So, in this case, they
have around 5,000 clients
that are connecting to a
single Filestore instance.
And around 500-ish of them
are active at any given
point of time.
In this case, the
biggest win for them
is they can get away from
the business of maintaining
their powerful servers and
actually focus on fuzz testing
and add value there.
So that was pretty powerful.
If you think about this,
this is the example
of small file
metadata-intensive workload
that you can try to
[? crash ?] the server with.
Tad?
TAD HUNT: Cool.
So Filestore's a part of an
ecosystem, not just Filestore
and not just native products.
It's part of an ecosystem
of partnerships.
And the partners are good
at various kinds of things.
And Filestore's good at
various kinds of things.
So when Filestore's
not the best choice,
it may be because you
have a workload that
needs, maybe, scale-out
performance, in which case
you might want to go with
somebody like Elastifile there.
Maybe you need a rich
and deep feature set
or maybe you're working
with a vendor on prem
and you're beginning
your Cloud journey.
And so maybe
somebody like NetApp
is your optimal partner there.
And again, maybe you have
a lot of distributed sites
and they all are
sharing files for
desktop-level collaboration,
end user collaboration.
Something like see CTERA and
Panzura are awesome there.
And, of course, there's
many more partners
for a wide variety of use cases.
So meeting you where
you are is what
we're trying to help
enable here on GCP.
And sometimes that
will mean Filestore
with a native product.
And sometimes that's
going to mean a partner.
So we've got you covered.
So that's enough high level.
Is everyone super
excited about demos?
KASHI VISHWANATH: Yes.
TAD HUNT: Is that
everybody's favorite part?
All right, cool.
So let me talk to you
about media rendering
as an interesting demo here.
So a typical process we
see with simulation artists
is they fire a bunch
of simulations off
at the same time.
And then they're going to
compare and contrast and then
pick the best one.
And that's the one
then they're going
to go send to a big,
large-scale render.
To do that
efficiently, they need
to harness a bunch of GPUs.
And they need a fast file
system shared in order
to actually do this and
get the real-time feedback.
So this is a IOPS.
And this is a performance
throughput heavy tasks
because we don't want the
multiple simulations to be
bogged down just
because one of the sims
is using up all of
the I/O bandwidth.
All right, so let's
switch to the demo screen.
All right, cool.
So because we offer high
IOPS in the single instance,
you saw on the earlier slide
up to 30,000 read IOPS,
this is actually possible
to do with a single instance
on Filestore, even
though you have
a lot of simulations
running, kind of spread
out concurrently.
In order to demo this, I'm
not going to run a simulation.
I am not a simulation artist.
I have absolutely no graphic
design talent whatsoever.
So what I am going
to do is I'm going
to show you a synthetic
benchmark running FIO, which
is a very common tool that's
used to do file system
performance testing.
I'm going to do a 50-50
read-write workload that's
going to test IOPS.
And so this is a
Filestore Premium instance
mounted on a single, eight
core VM on the client side
and running against 4K
random iOS, 50-50 read-write.
And then what I'm going to show
you behind here-- let's see,
I don't need that anymore.
What I'm going to show you is
the metrics from the NFS client
here.
And you can see on the top
left, we've got read throughput.
Top right, we got
write throughput.
And in the bottom we
have aggregate IOPS
split into read and write,
stacked on top of each other.
So just for fun, because
what we're talking about
is IOPS for this workload, I'm
going to zoom in on IOPS here.
And while the FIO script
is pushing all this traffic
back and forth from a single VM,
effectively what we're doing,
is we're simulating a sim.
And so it's turtles all
the way down, right?
All right, yeah,
my attempt at humor
aside, my jokes to
fill in the time
while the workload actually
ramps up is pretty funny.
All right, so what we're seeing
here is the NFS client has--
this is performance
measured at the NFS client,
not at the NFS server because
that's what you really
care about, right?
You care about what performance
is the client going to see.
And so the client is a
n1-standard-8 with a Prometheus
reporting agent installed,
reporting out to a Prometheus
server, and then
the real-time stats
being modeled with Grafana.
And so what you see here
is IOPS, combined IOPS,
of north of 35,000, so close to
40,000 IOPS for this workload.
Blue is read.
And pink-ish-- is that a
pink-- is write workloads.
I mean, you can
get rid of those.
You don't need those
little popups there.
As this workload
load runs, you see
it's doing a 50-50 read-write.
And so you'll see about equal--
over time, you'll see about
equal area under each curve.
And then they're stacked
so you can see aggregate
is 40,000, which is pretty good.
How many people here have
deployed file servers?
40,000 IOPS a pretty good
number for Cloud file server?
Yeah, right.
OK.
For those of you who haven't
deployed file servers,
this is a great number.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
And see, nobody's arguing with
me, so I assume this is good.
And then something
to look forward to
is there's kind of two
truisms about storage systems.
They're never big enough.
And they always
need to be faster.
Again, no quibbles there, right?
And so, I think you can imagine
that, over time, Filestore
will get, not only
bigger, but also faster.
Let's see.
Is there anything else I
want to talk about here?
I think that's basically it.
You see the performance level.
I'm going to hand it
back over to Kashi now.
And he's going to
drill down into some
of our technical specs.
Switch back to the--
awesome.
KASHI VISHWANATH: Yeah, as
we were switching the screen,
I was thinking about
my product manager
promising to you all that
we'll get bigger and faster.
And I don't know how I
feel about that right now.
But thanks for that.
TAD HUNT: I didn't
commit us to a timeline.
KASHI VISHWANATH: Thank you.
It's a fully managed service
that we've been talking about,
like most managed
services you've
seen in the Google portfolio.
Nevertheless, there
are stats and features
that you care about to make
sure you pick the right one.
In terms of share size,
you can grow all the way up
to 64 terabyte.
That's where the joke on
we need bigger comes in.
If you have any
feature requests,
we will have a few links
towards the end of the slide.
There will also
be a Q&A session.
And the standard support
channels and technical account
managers will work to give
us feedback on what we could
do to meet you where you are.
In terms of share resize,
I demoed that earlier.
You'll start with
something small.
You pay for it.
You think you need
a little bit more.
And dynamically, you
can update the size.
Your workload can
continue to run.
It's not going to
see a blip, right?
We're shipping,
right off the bat,
with NFSv3 support with locks.
In terms of clients, the
example that I showed you about
is beyond even testing.
I showed you an example
where the customer's running
production workloads with up
to 5,000 clients, around 500
active at the same time.
So think of that as the
scale, pretty powerful.
You get Google-grade
encryption at rest, private IP.
The project that
you're going to use
to create the fileshare is the
only place, the shared VPC,
is the only place the
visibility will exist.
So you do not be worried about
any other accidental leaks
and things like that.
It's a beta product right now--
we announced 10 days back.
So while it doesn't have
any SLA guarantee right now,
in GA time frame
you can look forward
to [? 3/9 ?] of [INAUDIBLE].
But that's just a really
big number, right?
Realistically, you should
not expect more than a couple
of minutes, even in the
worst case of downtime
at any given instance.
And thereto, assuming
you're doing hard mounts,
you guys are probably
experts at this.
Your application is not
going to see any blip.
We talked about the three
ways of accessing it.
One is the API.
One is the command line.
And we did do a demo.
We're exporting some of
the metrics to Stackdriver
right now.
You can read it off here.
Again, based on feedback
and as the product evolves,
this will only get
richer over time.
You will have the
ability to both monitor
and set alerts, which
come standard with many
of our products in Google.
Filestore is no different.
Tad?
TAD HUNT: Cool.
During Q&A, if you have a
detailed feature, queries,
definitely speak up.
Let me talk a minute about
pricing and availability.
So at GA, when we go General
Availability in the future,
we plan to be in
every GCP region.
But in the meantime,
while were in beta,
these are the regions that
Filestore is available in
and the regional pricing.
And so as you can see, the
Standard tier is roughly $0.20
a gig per month.
And that Premium tier is
roughly $0.30 a gig per month.
A little bit of
regional variability
there but not too much.
So Filestore is
billed hourly, right?
And so, you don't have to
pay for the whole month.
You only pay, if
you use it, you're
only billed down to the hour.
And so you're talking,
like, a ten thousandth
of a cent per hour or something.
There we go.
So on the integration
front, we are already
integrated with a bunch
of Google products
and a bunch of partner
products, which
I'll talk about in a
few minutes or we'll
talk about in a few minutes.
On Google side, we're integrated
with a Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, Deployment
Manager, VPC networking,
and Stackdriver.
Some of this we've
already talked about.
And so we're not going to
drill in there too much.
I want to say a note
about Compute Engine is
that if you're running
batched-processed workloads,
you'll often be using
preemptable VMs, which
are fully supported.
And a cool thing
with preemptable VMs,
right, is they
might get torn down
and a new one restarted for you.
But Filestore will actually
work in that VM as well.
And it'll go down and
back up and everything.
So that's great.
Kashi's going to talk to you
about our GKE, our Kubernetes
engine integrations.
KASHI VISHWANATH:
So I hope everybody
got the drift on GKE integration
in this conference, right?
So Filestore product
is no different.
We have a couple of ways
of doing that for you.
There is static provisioning
and dynamic provisioning.
You can see a sample
code YAML on the right.
I would personally not
take that and compile.
But you get the idea.
The idea is you can use it using
the standard interface volume
plug-in.
You create the persistent volume
claim, plug in the fileshare.
One way to obtain that would be
the demo I showed you earlier.
Plug that in, and
you're good to go.
So it should work with
Google Kubernetes Engine.
We also have the
dynamic provisioning, so
the next slide.
And a big shout out
to the GKE team, who
we've worked with internally.
Using this, we just released
to GitHub the CSI driver.
The URL is down there.
Using that, you can
dynamically create and mount
these fileshare.
Your workloads do not have
to know about the existence
of them a priori.
Furthermore, you can create
multiple search instances
and dynamically attach them.
Again, sample code
is on the right.
The driver example is all there.
And we'll have more
documentation coming up front.
So message is fully
integrated with GKE.
TAD HUNT: Very cool.
So continuing on the
integration front,
one of the common things you
need to do with storage systems
is the dreaded backup.
Anyone here had to do backups
for your storage systems
for your file servers?
Never fun.
Not super sexy thing to do.
But you've got to do it.
And you got to test restores.
And you're going
to probably have
to do actual restores
from time to time.
So on that front,
chances are you're
working with some
commercial partners already,
some commercial vendors
for that already.
We're announcing already an
integration with Actifio.
And there's a solutions brief.
And they're available on the
Cloud Launcher right there.
And so a really cool
thing about Actifio Sky
is it enables tiering
of your backup data
into GCS, into Google
Cloud Storage, where
you can use Nearline
and Coldline as well
to further reduce costs there.
And it enables rewind and
restoration of entire file
systems or even
just single files
at different points in time.
If there's other backup
providers that you use,
feel free to speak
up during the Q&A.
And we'll start open the
conversations with them.
So wrapping it up
and just before we
go to Q&A, which I think
we've got about 15,
20 minutes for, it's
actually perfect timing,
I want to leave you with
one key message here, which
is Filestore is a
new native experience
for standing up managed file
servers in Google Cloud.
And it works with Kubernetes
Engine and Compute Engine.
Kashi, you want to talk
about the resources?
KASHI VISHWANATH: Sure.
So the Web UI, many of you
who have used Google products
know how to get there.
So we have a Filestore
[? URI ?] towards the end.
That's the standard way.
You can reach out the
overview and documentation
that we've listed here.
It should walk you through
the examples of G Cloud,
how to use the UI, how to
create a fileshare, how
to do the update, and a bunch
of quick starts and tutorials.
So please take a look
and share feedback
if you have any on them.
And finally, a couple
of mailing lists
towards the end where we will
share information about what
you can look forward to.
And in return, the
last one is where
you can tell us how the
experience has been for you.
What is it that you found good?
What is it that you
want us to work on?
And what is it that you
want us to work on faster?
So all that is
awesome, helpful data.
Again, [INAUDIBLE] beta
product, so looking forward
to all the feedback and
making your lives better
in that process.
[MUSIC PLAYING]